has a bigger role in voice on the team
Westbrook from deep Adams with the
putback
the top offensive rebounders in the
games Brooke the loose ball rebound
breathe in and out move missed a layup
Adams has back coming out of halftime
everybody gets a good warm-up in before
the game the halftime warm up there's a
lot of guys still dragging out like that
looking for three four three four you
know inside Adams with the floater Jay
isn't working on all cylinders tonight
Thunder defense starting to put its foot
in the ground
Indiana's missed night offensively for
Western has been very differential and a
good decision that time to grant for the
lane nunavut on the drive it's a heavy
traffic ended up on his back and the
Thunder have numbers the other way
George for three parter ball three
consecutive threes doing an 80 no
thunder one easy Paul George wide open
from downtown to Jeremy grant and
getting his hands on the ball I got two
grand driving kick West with head all
day to tee it up and he used all parts
of the rim and knocked it down
well good ball movement grant with the
nice pass and Westbrook rattle with one
home let's flip inside to Adams nice
looking around off glass with the left
hands oh and he's a little dream shape
almost dear Jeff OH
now mark does not get carried away but a
nice little pivot move towards going to
work here physical against Matthews
Wow I mean that's an offensive foul
[Music]